now your memory your memory is a hard
worker okay when you think about all the
different kinds of things you have to
remember people subjects how many times
do you study at the same time it just
gets bigger when you go into next year
you become senior students so do you
memory fit okay the first thing to do is
to make notes okay when it comes to
notes right there are a few different
things you can do in that's right and
they're not all the same for instance
you can read someone else's notes all
the notes of the textbook something like
that and that's good that's better than
not reading at all okay but don't be
under any illusion that just really
notes is going to get you all that much
benefit okay it's it's basic level right
wouldn't it better than that is to
actually take some notes and copy them
out because that's you getting your pen
know type it okay it's not the same and
actually try to take what you got and
think about what's important okay and
copy some that down putting you in word
sort but what's been even better than
copying better again is to actually
create your own notes get a few
different kinds of resources write
different text books different
worksheets different friends right and
then put together your own notes that's
what I mean by not just any notes okay
the kinds of things you want to include
for birds right you wanna think about
for years okay now I don't we hate
formulas because like is so impossible
to remember like honestly who can
remember that C squared equals a squared
plus B squared minus 2c seriously anyone
okay now oh yeah I just did you know
I've been teaching you use now the way I
think about formulas is rather thinking
man it's a pain to memorize formulas a
better name for formulas is really
shortcuts that's what they are okay
because you know what this is for is for
working out the length of a side in a
triangle given the other two sides enemy
okay now you can do that from scratch
without a formula and it will take you
forever right but someone has done the
work to think about a shortcut that will
just get you there in one line okay so
that's how I think about those table now
any notes you've got your formulas
shortcuts okay one other thing is really
useful for you is to have some key
examples find some tough questions find
the ones you know you struggle with okay
and then think about okay how did they
do that how did the textbook put out a
solution right
you know you're right out your solution
it's gonna use making lines okay and
then you don't just have the solution
there you highlight parts you like okay
this is step one I had to do this okay
here's another step down here right that
represents something different how do I
remember that okay incarnate highlight
underline use colors all those kinds of
things will help